Welcome back everyone this is my spider-man
no way home video for that big thing that just
happened last night that everyone's talking
about some pictures of tobey maguire andrew
garfield and daredevil in the movie were posted
all over everyone's timelines so i'll explain
what's going on with that and what it means
because we saw this coming but we kind of
didn't see this coming you know post all your
quicksilver memes you didn't see that's coming
if you're brand new to the channel i do marvel
videos every week be sure to subscribe to get
everything we're also doing a giveaway for
disney plus memberships because disney plus
day is happening later this week it's going to
be like trailer city they're dropping a bunch
of marvel trailers for the series as well as
a bunch of news and announcements for upcoming
really big stuff so of course i'll be doing videos
for all those things as well too but recently you
probably saw your entire timeline turn into
spider-man marvel sony and kevin feige memes
if you have no idea why everyone was going so
spider-man crazy is because an online journalist
posted two pictures that he claims were sent to
him featuring tobey maguire spider-man andrew
garfield spider-man and tom hall and spider-man
together in a scene in their spider-man suits
in a separate picture of a scene featuring charlie
cox's matt murdock daredevil with peter parker
aunt may and happy around the dinner table more
to that too the person who originally posted these
pictures said that they actually got a phone
call from a sony representative asking them
all the business where did you get these who gave
them to you why did you post them why did you put
your watermark on them it got crazy so i'm not
gonna post the pictures in this video here just
for copyright reasons if they really are authentic
i don't want marvel or sony trying to mess with my
video it literally happened right after i've
posted a new spider-man no way home video
for about the first hour all the comments just
read have you seen the pictures have you seen the
pictures have you seen the pictures that feels
weird but i'll allow it yes i definitely saw
the pictures but normally you wouldn't think
too much about people posting toby mcguire
andrew garfield daredevil pictures this kind of
stuff because ever since the movie was announced
there's been so much fan art out there and the
vast majority of us believe that tobey maguire
and andrew garfield were going to be in the movie
somewhere anyway in some kind of scenes so it was
really just a question of exactly what they'd be
doing in the movie and how many scenes they got
but then what happened the reason why this turned
into a full-blown spider-man meme event just
clowning on this person who initially posted the
pictures was because many of the regular scoopers
the people who are usually the ones releasing
stuff like this or confirming whether or not it's
actually real leaking things claim that these
new pictures that you saw over your timelines
are actually legit like the real and the scenes
that they depict are actually in the movie now to
be fair they do look a little photoshopped like
if you are an experienced photoshop artist some
aspects of them don't quite add up they don't look
totally real but even if they're just elaborate
concept art mock-ups done by the artists who are
working on the movie the idea is that versions
of these scenes are supposed to be in the movie
according to all the collective leakers on the
internet so you do have to take it with a grain
of salt but the tobii mcguire spider-man andrew
garfield and tom holland spider-man scene depicts
them standing on one of the railings around the
statue of liberty with their respective spider-man
costumes and their masks off talking to each other
and someone off frame before a big fight scene
it seems like they're all looking at someone or
something off the right side of the frame as if
there's someone you can't see in the picture that
they're wise cracking with or something they're
wise cracking about tobey maguire's spider-man
costume looks exactly like it did in his
spider-man movies same thing for andrew garfield's
amazing spider-man costume andrew garfield almost
doesn't look like he's aged a day toby mcguire is
sporting the short haircut that you've seen in all
the recent photos of him on the internet around
hollywood and tom hall and spider-man is wearing
his newer advanced suit the steve ditko inspired
red and black suit from spider-man far from
home they're just calling that the advanced suit
during the movie a lot of people are claiming he's
supposed to have a different suit near the end of
the movie and it sounds like the scene that this
depicts with all three of them together is later
in the movie but there was a recent preview of one
of his fight scenes that showed him on what looks
like dr octopus's fusion reactor from spider-man 2
just crouched ready to fight them he doesn't have
his mask on and he's wearing the same advanced
suit even though it has a lot of battle damage
sometimes it can be hard to tell what's really
going on in the previews that they released
because sony and marvel have a lot of clever
photoshopping and trickery with their trailers
they edit trailers in very misleading ways to hide
details the daredevil scene that this journalist
posted shows matt murdock in a gray suit that
looks very similar to the one that he wore
throughout the daredevil netflix series sitting
at the dinner table in aunt may and peter parker's
new house in queens with happy they look pretty
chill like they're all just discussing something
and no one's wearing their superhero costume like
they're just sitting around talking as if matt
murdock is there more as a lawyer first and as a
superhero giving sage wisdom second and a lot of
people are trying to connect dots because recently
tom holland talked about a scene that sounds like
this he talked about filming a scene in a movie
that kind of blew his mind that was really amazing
sitting around a dinner table talking about what
it means to be a superhero with a new secret
character that they had not announced for the
movie yet so a lot of people are like maybe that's
matt murdock's daredevil so when the journalist
posted this scene depicting that exactly people
kind of freaked out but if it's actually legit
the daredevil scene actually kind of looks more
like concept art the way the characters look
physically just doesn't totally seem real in the
background of their apartment inside the picture
doesn't match 100 the scene during the trailer
like the shelves in the background are a little
bit different some of the books are different
the pictures are in different places so had
the collective internet knock on crazy over
this last night and said that these were all real
i would have said that this daredevil scene was
probably a fake the tobey maguire andrew garfield
scene looks a little more authentic than the matt
murdock scene but if you viewed the scenes the
pictures let me know in the comments if you
think that they're real and what your theories are
about what's going on in them during the movie the
tobey maguire andrew garfield team up scene shares
some similar aspects to that andrew garfield blue
screen scene everyone was posting earlier this
year there were a couple pictures then there was
a full-blown clip of andrew garfield in his
amazing spider-man costume with the mascot
sitting on a guardrail in front of this giant blue
screen and supposedly he was mouthing the words
web blood people said it was fake people said
it was real everyone went crazy over it it's
still a big question mark but web blood is
a reference to toby mcguire's web shooters
in the tobey mcguire spider-man movies one
of the changes they made to his origin story
was to give him organic web shooters seeing his
body produced the webbing like an actual spider
andrew garfield and tom holland spider-man were
a little more comic book accurate and they gave
their versions mechanical web shooters so that's
why andrew garfield's spider-man would be wise
cracking about toby having webb blood in fun
fact the organic web shooters were actually a
holdover idea from the james cameron spider-man
movie in the mid 90s before sam raimi was hired
to make the first tobey maguire spider-man movie
james cameron was developing a spider-man movie
at sony in the mid-90s his spider-man would have
been leonardo dicaprio because this was happening
as we were getting ready to reach peak young
leonardo dicaprio like right before he did titanic
but then james cameron left the project and they
brought sam raimi on and he wound up casting tobey
maguire and the rest was history but several plot
elements from james cameron's spider-man script
were incorporated into toby maguire's spider-man
movie so we'll see if there any other easter eggs
or references to that in the upcoming spider-man
movies like spider-verse 2 but as for daredevil
there have been reports as early as last year that
he was going to be in the movie in some way but at
the time my expectation was that it would just
be like a really small cameo scene it would be
matt murdock it wouldn't be actual daredevil in a
daredevil costume it would just have something to
do with the mysterio storyline and spider-man's
identity because he's a lawyer it would be a
really easy way to incorporate him in the movie in
a really small quick way when that first trailer
came out during this interrogation scene so many
people swore that they thought that this person
was matt murdock but charlie cox sworn his life
that these were not his forearms like that's not
me then they released the imax version of the
trailer and it showed more footage at the top
and the bottom of the frame revealing this person
confirming that it was not him it's this other
detective who's grilling him about the drones
so if matt murdock really does show up in the
movie to help him with this little police problem
it's at some other point during the movie everyone
post all your theories about that but for those of
you who want marvel to make a legit new daredevil
series on disney plus i've done a few videos
recently about all the upcoming movies and other
marvel disney plus series that charlie cox and
the daredevil characters are supposed to cameo in
the hawkeye episodes are supposed to feature some
vincent d'onofrio kingpin for example the echo
spin-off series with her character is supposed to
feature daredevil and kingpin the she-hulk series
is supposed to have a daredevil cameo because
he's a lawyer just like she is and there have
been reports about marvel actually working on a
legit daredevil revival series on disney plus with
most of the original characters but here's the
thing charlie cox said that if he did come back
that he might wind up being a slightly reimagined
version of the character like not a full reboot
or anything just a slight creative retuning so
instead of bringing it back as daredevil season
4 it would be more like daredevil season 1 of a
brand new storyline and his costume might look a
little bit different but it would still be most of
the original characters from the daredevil netflix
series i will be doing videos for all the hawkeye
episodes starting in a couple weeks so we won't
have to wait that long to find out what's going on
with all this and maybe they'll announce some news
on disney plus day with all the trailers of course
i'll be doing videos for all those on friday and
this weekend so make sure to enable alerts
for my channel so you don't miss any of those
if you think it's crazy now just wait a couple
weeks till the next spider-man trailer comes out
congratulations ricardo morales you're the
giveaway winner for my last big marvel video
please email me on the about page of my channel
so i can get your details everyone click here
for my full eternals post credit scene
video and click here for that new version
of the spider-man no way home trailer and new
sinister six easter eggs on the official poster
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!